Josie is with us in New Jersey hi Josie
how are you
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up I'm good I want to I
had a question I just got off of a phone
call with my father and he had told me
that he just had a very large tree ruin
his roof not too long ago and he called
any ask for some money and I don't have
homeowners insurance he does but it's
not going to cover the full cost
why not I don't know I asked him the
same question because it didn't make my
sense that they would only cover part of
it and you still have a third of a roof
to fill in the gaps so his statement was
that he is basically shorted difference
between things that he can fund of about
4 K for the contractor to finish finish
the job essentially I don't know why the
homeowners insurance well yeah he's 62
and why is he broke that's a very good
question he's not very good of money I
guess that's the short answer of it how
much money well I make about ninety one
thousand dollars a year my husband makes
more than me and together we I've paid
off all of my college debt over five
years ago and you know we've made it
work I worked baby steps a long time ago
how much more money than you how much
money do you guys have together it's I
mean gross amount that's probably ninety
one plus no no I'm gonna talk about John
do you have any money
we've got our fully our full emergency
fund fully stocked
how much more at leftover beyond that
we're paying our daughters college
savings right now we've maxed out our
401ks so we are doing all of that so you
have a household income of like two
hundred thousand and you
getting up through baby step three
you've been working the plan and how
much is in your emergency fund about
fifty K okay alright so if you give your
dad four thousand dollars it's not going
to kill you well we're we're working on
some inside hustles and just to passion
projects and that kind of thing and
that's usually where our leftover money
has been going into in order to in order
to give your dad some free money for his
roof which doesn't even make sense so no
I would not loan him money if you decide
that you want to get to the bottom of
this and require him to start doing some
smarter things with money you would give
him the money but no I would never
loaning the money because all that's
gonna happen there he's gonna disappoint
you he can't pay you because he
mishandles money and then you're gonna
be mad at your dad your dad's gonna be
embarrassed and ashamed to be with his
daughter and we don't need to do all
that the borrower's slave to the lender
you're gonna change your relationship
just give him the money if you're going
to but I smell a rat yeah I think dad's
full of crap he kinda has had a history
of trying to get money out of us in the
past and that makes my husband not very
keen on giving him money to be honest I
know that's not going to be great
conversation later you know I'm I'm
worried about him but we haven't yep it
makes me nervous well I mean it's not
logic okay if you have a tree hit your
roof and the whole roof has to be
replaced homeowners pays for all of it
minus the deductible there's only one
program there's not a you cannot buy a
homeowner's policy that pays for part of
your roof they don't exist
okay dad's dad's running the scam here
oh boy I mean unless something's wrong
with the story right yeah he spent the
insurance money and got the content and
then doesn't enable to pay the
contractor and he's got himself found
pinched I know he's trying to pay off a
divorce at the same time so I don't know
you spent the insurance money and now
he's got the contractor and he's in a
pinch yeah it's what sounds like I don't
know but you can run it to ground if you
want to run it to ground you can close
your eyes and be in denial and throw him
for grand but you can't loan it to him I
would say dad yeah if it were me I would
run it to ground make sure he's not
scamming me and then if I determine that
it's a real need and it takes a little
more time and effort and tears and he's
probably not gonna like it you
questioning him which I don't really
give a rip he's the one asking you for
money you know so you know you're gonna
ask him stuff that's uncomfortable for
him and if you decided to legitimate
need then you say I will give you the
$4,000 but on one condition that you
attend Financial Peace University dad
this is a lifelong pattern of you
misbehaving with money and it's time to
stop that's my cost for this gift